Crowd: Good morning John, it's Friday!
[Music]
Well a pheasant is a bird
And they need to be plucked
After being slaughtered
And before they're put on trucks
And you probably
Don't think much of me
Just a lonely pheasant plucker at the pheasant
factory
But my life as a mother pheasant plucker is
pleasant
Just listening to music as I pluck mother
pheasants
I'm a pleasant pheasant plucker
And nobody's ever heard
A pleasant mother pheasant plucker like me
say the F-word
And I come from a mother pheasant plucking
family
From the mother pheasant plucking plantation in Italy
And the days were hard And the nights were long
And so to keep their spirits high, they sang this song
They said my life as a mother pheasant plucker is pleasant
Just listening to music as I pluck mother pheasants
I'm a pleasant pheasant plucker and nobody's ever heard
A pleasant mother pheasant plucker like me say the F-word.
My mother was a mother pheasant plucker as well. And she loved to pluck the mother pheasants yes I could tell
And she sang this song as she plucked all day long. She never, ever, ever got the lyrics wrong.
She sang My life as a mother pheasant plucker is pleasant, just listening to music as I pluck mother pheasants.
I'm a pleasant pheasant plucker, and nobody's ever heard a pleasant mother pheasant plucker like me say the F-word.
Because my life as a mother pheasant plucker is pleasant, just listening to music as I pluck mother pheasants.
Because my life as mother pheasant plucker is pleasant, just listening to music as I pluck mother pheasants.
I'm a pleasant pheasant plucker, and nobody's ever heard a pleasant mother pheasant plucker like me say the F-word.
I'm a pleasant pheasant plucker, and nobody's ever heard a pleasant mother pheasant plucker like me say the F-woooooooord.
Thank to Shmorky and Weebl for making that music video for me. I lost my wife. We've
been playing that song on tour. It's been
going poorly, which is the point. We're headed
now to a friend of ours' house. Tour has been
amazing. Is it going well?
Katherine: Yeah, it's going great.
Hank: Thank you so much to all the people
who have come out to spend time with Hank
Green and The Perfect Strangers and Harry
and the Potters and Driftless Pony Club and
Andrew Huang and Rob Scallon. I'm not sharing
a ton of behind the scenes stuff from the
tour on this video or any videos because I'm
putting it all into the Podcast Because Awesome
which is a behind the scenes tour diary of
the Tour Because Awesome. If you like podcasts
that are, like, twenty to thirty minutes apiece,
and it's just what life is like on tour for
a nerd band.
Final bit of news: the Bat People shirts are
only going to be on sale for another, like,
twelve or twenty-four hours or so, so if you
want to get one of those, this is your last
chance. And I have arrived at my friend's
house. My friend Barack Obama.
Thanks again to Shmorky and Weebl, there's
links in the description for them, and thank
you to everyone who's come out to see us on
tour. It's been a really fantastic time. I've
had a great time. It feels like a lot of other
people have as well, so thanks. And John,
I'll see you on Tuesday.
Last time I was here I was in it. That's weird.